foreign
[Music]
guys that are just sort of there for for
the Brotherhood and the Fidel that they
they want to wear the jacket they want
to like hang out they want to be in the
clubhouse but they're they're not the
guy who's got to run in when when you're
being outnumbered you come across those
guys as well yeah yeah so so you're
showing that you're not that guy right
right yeah because it seems like you
know and look man I know I know so much
about your story we're friends you know
so like I've heard a lot of these
stories but one sort of recurring theme
with you just always seems It's always
somebody did something that you felt was
unjust somebody hurt somebody that you
love somebody put their hands on a woman
and so you go and you react right yeah
what what was um I mean this club now is
starting to become your family was there
like one inciting incident that then
ratcheted it up to to another level yeah
and and that became so we so in 1994 we
switched from we switched from the
hell's henchmen to the how we became
Hells Angels right we were talking to to
the Hell's Angels and one of the
henchmen was in was in the penitentiary
with an angel out of Minnesota and we he
they had a good relationship with each
other and the Hell's Angels at the time
were never in the midwest it was
Minnesota and then you know uh nothing
in the Midwest and then it was Ohio so
there was that big gap of no Hell's
Angels right there you know and we were
the opportunity right the hell's
henchmen you know three chapters guys
that were you know about it and stuff
like that so once we decided that we
were going to become Hell's Angels well
that changed the game in the history of
Chicago because the Outlaws that was
their Hometown that was their their
their their their chapter that the
Chicago chapter was you know on the map
how does that decision give me
um all of us took it to a vote there was
some older guys in the club that were
hell's henchmen at the time that you
know knew that they didn't want to take
that next step and we couldn't blame
them you know at the time I was you know
22 23 years old and uh these guys were
you know 40s and 50s and they're
thinking okay once we make this decision
to become Hell's Angels it's it's going
to turn the city upside down here the
Outlaws are not going to be happy with
this and you know we don't know what's
coming but we knew they weren't going to
be happy so some guy split we gave them
the opportunity we said you can't keep
the club the hell's henchmen has to fold
and come Hell's Angels you can't keep
the club you know so guys left the guys
that stayed made the decision to stay
and we kind of buckled up for the ride
because the Outlaws told us there's
nothing more for us to talk about it's
on you know mortal enemies at the time
how did they send you that message we
were we sat with him at a table they had
called you know the the at the time that
the president was a guy that was the
hell's henchen president for probably 15
years
and uh they hit him up and five of us
went to meet five of them at a
restaurant and they asked if the rumor
was true and we said yeah we're doing it
we're we're going to become Hell's
Angels and uh they said okay there's
nothing more for us to talk about see
you when we see you and I knew right
then and there at when them cats left
that table it was going to get serious
so what and then what is that so what's
like once you leave that table what's
the conversation like what what does
that feel like is there any part of your
like [__] it's it's it's on now or are
you like bring whatever comes and I'm
super young at the time and these cats
are you know 10 12 15 years older than
me that just you know on the outlaw side
too and serious cats right we The
Outlaws had a very very
tough reputation these guys weren't uh
pushovers by any means you know they had
a very hardcore crew and in these five
cats that came from their team were the
hardcore dudes and I looked in and
looked in their eyes and seen it you
know and uh when we were leaving and I
said well we we kind of knew the outcome
we were gonna get yeah we knew nothing
was going to happen at the time we were
in a restaurant we picked you know we
all picked a restaurant where it was you
know neutral and uh we were just you
know going home saying well boys no
we've got to see what's going to happen
here you know we didn't we weren't
taking anything to them they were not
happy with what we were doing so we were
kind of like sitting back and seeing how
it was going to go and things escalated
very fast very fast
um
um the beating started the bar room
stuff catching a couple guys in the bars
they jumped a few of our guys we
returned the favor and it started that
way and um and then it's like they took
a step up with the violence and we had
to try to take the step up to do it
right there's no Playbook right it's not
your reading from it's like you have to
be Johnny on the spot and come you know
take what comes your way and that's how
we were all doing it right none of us
really knew anything I mean when they
put the bomb on our clubhouse in 1994
that was the third largest bomb to this
day it was like the Oklahoma
McVeigh it was um uh the trades Towers
you know in New York and this was the
third largest bomb detonated in the
United States to this day and uh was you
know we didn't know about bombs I could
barely put the battery in my pager
you know we didn't I didn't put you know
all I did with motorcycles I put the gas
in how did that go how did the bomb go
to did the what happened what was the
story with that so there they um put a
hundred pounds of C4 in a car
shaped it and everything like that
drove it up our clubhouse was on a in a
crazy it was called Grand Avenue and it
was a very busy street and it was about
five o'clock you know in a weekday
afternoon it was a Tuesday Wednesday or
something like that middle of the week
traffic going by and everything and uh
they
built they built the bomb in the trunk
of this car and one of their members who
you know got ricoed and went to prison
it's all you know this is God Gangland
stuff and every you know knowledgeable
he drove the car
in in Black the front door of the
clubhouse because they thought people
were in the clubhouse because there was
some cars out in front there was a
member from Minnesota with his girl
visiting but they were sightseeing at
the time
and that thing he got out of the car the
car picked them up you see from the
cameras and he barely got out of view of
the cameras you know block or so away
and that thing detonated and by the
grace of God
two minutes before that a city bus went
by filled with people CTA bus you see a
cop car goes by real slow and the cop
looks at the door and he goes well it's
probably the Angels you know we were
that neighborhood the henchmen been
there since the 60s
oh that's probably the Angels doing
moving something I mean if he would have
stopped and got out nobody would have
lived through this so that bomb goes off
you know it blasts down and it blew up
five six seven foot hole in the ground
they found the VIN number a mile away
right well when the ATF gets in there
and does you know does their
investigation
hits the front door big steel front door
blows it out of the back of the of the
building through it you know a big
building you know Old Chicago building
three levels the blast goes across the
street there's a house that's siding
like aluminum siding house by the grace
of God nobody's in the house it just
rips the house apart
nobody can start knocks all the lights
out on on off or for blocks around I
mean just turmoil right so I was sitting
at home and I get a phone call and from
one of my friends and he goes hey bro I
I think your Clubhouse is on the news
and I go well he goes turn on the news I
go what channel he goes any of them and
I turn on the news and I look and I'm
just seeing the city the the block but
with no lights
the the car piece is far infernos on the
streets and I think we've seen it in the
sizzle reel of that you know where the
the guy was out there from the news and
stuff like that and I said yeah that's
our clubhouse you know so we all got it
got on the phone with each other and we
met a few blocks away there was a gas
station
we came down to the gas station and
stuff and it was just it was so crowded
it was like if you were there signing
autographs the place was just jammed
with people because they had everything
shut off nobody could get near it right
so we were all in a gas station we're
like man what happened here right and
the neighbors are like man an explosion
went off on Grand Avenue right and we're
like okay so um as I'm standing there
talking to the fellas I hear my name get
called hey Mel and I look around and
it's it's a couple ATF guys a couple
guys that I already knew who they were
and they said hey man come here we want
to talk to you I said okay they go uh
what's going on here I go I have no idea
man I just seen it on the news you know
they said well
who you thinking I go I don't have no
idea your guess is as good as mine right
you knew exactly I kind of figured it
was we didn't have anybody that you know
that was could do that at that capacity
that we knew besides some guys
so I see he goes it's a mess down there
man he goes it's it's a disaster I said
anybody heard he goes no nobody hurt
nobody was in the building I find out
later from you know from Lou and the ATF
guys you know it would have blast like
that if anybody was in that building it
would have just ripped their air drums
out they would have been bleeding
internally just from the concussion
right not the plastic concussion and
stuff like that and I said okay cool I
said uh can I see the place and he says
yeah if you talk to me I said yeah let's
go let's walk and talk you know how we
think it was the Outlaws I go well guys
I don't know I was at home I wasn't here
when somebody you know did this right
and I seen the building I seen the
street and I was like look like Beirut
when I used to watch the old because at
this point you're not interested you're
only interested at one kind of Justice
at this like you know exactly what
you're like yes yeah yeah what's that
feeling yeah that feeling was like like
so when I got back after seeing the
building and the in the and the FED said
okay we're seizing this now this is ours
we're having people flying from
Washington this is a big deal it's we'll
let you know when what's gonna happen
but we were taking over this this this
property right and I said okay you know
they were out there and the guys we had
guys it was our job as members to make
sure we were watching the building too
because they cleared the street up Grand
Avenue opened and we had guys that had
to sit out there in shifts 10 hour
shifts and stuff to make sure because
there was gaping holes in this building
but every day people were flying in from
Washington and you know going through
the place and making sure you know they
wanted to you know do all their
investigation and stuff
and at the time you know funny old
saying is I used to say man tie your
shoes up boys it's getting it's gonna
get crazy here right and uh you know we
were doing that Tit for Tat thing you
know and like I said none of us knew
that game so it became from
it was a personal level fighting running
in each other's bars doing stuff like
that you know to now wow this thing just
happened and turned the game around with
the bombing stuff right
laughs
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already board Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with about their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
year was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll